l'espèce de vous rappelez vous de cette
image avant noël quatre chefs politiques
qui s'élève au dessus de la mêlée pour
combattre la pandémie
c'est important qu'on soit ensemble de
parler à l'unisson par solidarité on est
unis ce quota côte du 22 décembre
dernier est redevenu un face à face
aujourd'hui au salon bleu on recule dans
les années 50 avec duplessis et
peut-être que ça va faire plaisir aux
premiers vinet cette allusion au chef de
l'opposition officielle avait promis
qu'après de la politique autrement
quelquefois je chiale et vidé ses
députés confiner les couloirs du
parlement son désert depuis des mois ce
la salle evelyne du mans a servi de
quartier général pour le trio de la
santé bienvenue à cette conférence de
presse du premier ministre du québec
françois lecourt irrité par le quasi
monopole du message gouvernemental livry
ici jour après jour les partis
d'opposition ronger leur frein en se
répétant que l'heure n'était pas à la
politique en pleine crise et en faisant
le pari que la popularité du premier
ministre finirait par s'affaiblir en
même temps que le virus un grand
développement économique le gouvernement
leur âge étaient en hausse le troisième
lien entre la capitale nationale et
chaudière appalaches le coup 1 milliard
de dollars par député cac est de la
région de québec martèlent les
adversaires 10 milliards du premier
ministre huit kilomètres d'autoroute
pour 10 député de la 4 voies québec
soldats tout ce qui m'intéresse c'est
montréal silence vous prendrez vous
rappellerez qu'on a deux députés à
québec quand on verra l'année prochaine
combien en reste puisque janot aucun
dans chaudière-appalaches où ça va
rester comme ça
pour ébranler les colonnes du parlement
durant la session les chefs devaient
tout misé sur les mardis et les jeudis
les seuls moments où ils pouvaient
confronté françois legault ici à la
période de questions
réunis eux aussi en bulles le premier
ministre et la vice première ministre
étaient présents à tour de rôle au salon
bleu l'équipe b a fait monter
l'impatience des partis d'opposition on
est en train de confondre ici gouverner
est réuni pour affronter la crise le
gouvernement s'est doté de pouvoirs
exceptionnels tous les dix jours en
décrétant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
sans l'assentiment de l'assemblée
nationale c'est un autre exemple de
mépris yassif frapin de la démocratie
aux yeux de l'opposition
c'est un manque de respect des règles
parlementaires de commun accord
le bus des pierres fils qui venait mois
que ce dernier va se retirer mais ils
ont fini par acculé françois legault au
pied du mur d'une autre institution
commissaire à l'éthique leur demande une
quatrième enquête sur le ministre de
l'économie et homme d'affaires pierre
fitzgibbon a forcé le premier ministre à
le sacrifier à la veille d'une relance
économique des entrepreneurs qui ont le
sens éthique ça existe parti québécois
là j'étais là ce qui les intéresse
assure nté à chaque fois que je parlerai
d'économies dans le caucus intérêt sa
propre personne mais c'est d'une bosse
incroyable
et raccourcie du premier ministre
aujourd'hui sont hallucinants le
déconfinement permettra aux parties de
sillonner le québec cet été à la
recherche de nouveaux candidats
mais comment tirer des femmes et des
hommes d'affaires aux politiques se
demandent la caq sans une réforme du
code d'éthique
je connais assez bien dominique anglade
manon massé et puis paul st pierre
plamondon savoir que lyon aucune volonté
c'est parti le leur en veulent pas
d'entrepreneurs c'est une quatrième
vague ne vient pas brouiller les cartes
cet automne les parties vont peser sur
l'accélérateur pour séduire les
québécois à un an des élections
ce qui laisse peu de temps pour les
chefs sur tous les nouveaux venus comme
dominique anglade et paul st pierre
plamondon pour faire fléchir la
popularité de françois legault